c'est un ajustement de mobilier c'est
une solidité avec des trappes qu'on a
vraiment en main c'est également des
tireurs profond avec des fonctions de
rappel avec un grand réfrigérateur tout
ça ce sont des points sans lesquelles on
ne va absolument pas touché on ne va
rien économiser sur notre nouveau
produit ainsi thierry veut garder tout
ce qui symbolise le luxe et qui éblouit
les clients quand ils montent à bord
intérieur design
ambiance cosy
plan de travail de la cuisine en marbre
douch avec éclairage fluo en bas
et lumières naturelles en eau
alors comment va faire notre français
pour garder tous ses équipements en fait
qu'ils arrivent à économiser sur ce que
les clients ne voit jamais
car à force de sculpter sous toutes les
coutures c'est camping car il a
découvert quelque chose qui avait
échappé aux allemands il s'est aperçu
qu'il utilisait ce châssis haut de gamme
il coûte très cher car il est ultra
léger et ultra résistants alors thiery a
décidé que pour son produit d'appel un
châssis en acier comme celui ci beaucoup
moins cher suffirait amplement
il est pour nous quelque part un peu
aberrant de demander à chaque client de
payer le surcoût d'un cheyssial co qui
peut représenter jusqu'à 4 à 5 % du coût
de revient global du camping car alors
qu'on en a pas besoin c'est là qu'on va
pouvoir faire de réelles économies
selon nos estimations en changeant ce
châssis thierry économisera 2000 euros
par camping car et puis il a trouvé une
autre source d'économies très astucieuse
la marque y meurt vend beaucoup de
camping cars dans les pays nordiques en
finlande en suède ou en norvège
dans ces pays le culte du camping car
est telle que les scandinaves
l'utilisent même en hiver par moins 25
degrés du coup les allemands ont mis le
paquet côté chauffage
seulement en france les hivers sont bien
plus doux
thierry a donc décidé de baisser la
puissance du chauffage ça lui permet
d'économiser 250 euros par camping car
mais ce n'est pas encore suffisant alors
pour réduire encore plus le prix notre
spécialiste va s'attaquer à la liste des
options
[Musique]
il y en a près d'une centaine et là il
va procéder à un tri impitoyable fini
les six moteurs différents désormais il
n'y en aura plus que trois finies aussi
les sièges chauffants
et puis il n'y aura plus trois couleurs
pour la cabine mais seulement une
leblanc il va supprimer ainsi une option
sur deux au catalogue et cela va baisser
considérablement le coût du camping car
en effet en usine la moindre option en
moins permet de standardiser la
production donc de travailler plus vite
du coup les dépenses peuvent baisser de
10 à 12%
grâce à toutes ces astuces thierry a
réussi à faire passer son futur camping
cars de 63000 euros à 57 mille euros
c'est grâce à ce genre de techniques
commerciales que les camping cars se
vendent par milliers en france nous
sommes même devenue le deuxième pays en
europe à en acheter autant et au beau
milieu de cet engouement un nouveau
moyen de partir à petit prix est en
train d'émerger
désormais il est possible d'accéder à
ces véhicules de rêve à un tarif
incroyable